last night you're all are out for dinner
and we find out something about you guys
your lambs riah posted on Instagram that
there's a new band in town Priyanka Nick
and Mariah wants to start the band
I'm all for Priyanka went to her show in
London I think actually while we were
there meeting with our London
distributors about to build one and she
had the best time and we were randomly
at the same restaurant as Mehran and
unfortunately she couldn't come to the
show tonight because she had her own
show but in Vegas we're gonna go see
Mariah
Nick Jonas is having all sorts of fun
these days not only is he living it up
on the Jonas Brothers happiness begins
tour
he's also launching a line of tequila
with designer John Varvatos called Villa
won congratulations how was the show
tonight and how did this all come about
show was insane Madison Square Garden
Arena in true completely John was there
with the family the loudest show I mean
when they said rock and roll shows were
loud this show just took it to a whole
other decibel level it's so much fun not
sure if you guys know but it is now
going viral there's a video of jay-z
rocking out and the quote is write the
quote is it's the year 3000 and jay-z's
at a Jonas Brothers concert what do you
think of that I mean he's a part of the
team I'm a rogue nation artist we are
rock nation artists and he wrote me said
I'm coming tonight
I can't wait and the fact that he was
there supporting during year 2000 is
kind of a let's talk about the tequila
how did this come together and do we
test it on the wives is Priyanka a
tequila drinker did you have a shot off
with her though she is the Reposado star
favorite so we've got you know the yaho
the shadow and the silver and she's
tried it all and she was there actually
the first time we went to our tequila
farm in tequila Mexico and was a big
part of the process and I think for us
you know family is the most important
and keeping this you know something that
our family and friends can enjoy
in the same way that first time we went
down there and had that amazing
experience and tried to create the
culture around villa one in fact that
she's here tonight but she was drinking
the Reposado with us is a special thing
[Music]